-Republicans are waging war
on Disney
and concocting some very bizarre
fictional scenarios
about its characters,
While a new lawsuit seeks
to keep Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
off the ballot in November
for trying to help overthrow
the 2020 election.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
You guys, as we have said
many times on this show,
the modern Republican Party is,
among many other things,
a collection of some of the
weirdest people in the world.
There's just no other way
to say it.
They constantly say
and do weird [bleep].
Like when North Carolina
Congressman Madison Cawthorn
[ Laughter ]
said he'd been invited
by members of Congress
to wild, drug-fueled orgies
he called sexual get-togethers.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, a Fox News host
promoted what he called
testicle tanning,
which apparently involves
exposing your balls
to something called
red light therapy.
And, guessing by his face,
Rudy Giuliani was the first
person to try it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Giuliani ]
I only have money
for one right now.
I'll be back next month
to finish the job.
[ Laughter ]
And then, on top of all that,
Texas Senator Ted Cruz whined
about Disney's opposition
to Florida's recent ban
on discussions of sexual
orientation or gender identity
in kindergarten
through third grade,
referred to by critics
as the Don't Say Gay bill,
by painting this incredibly
disturbing image
that we now all have
to live with.
-I think there are people
who are misguided,
trying to drive, you know,
Disney stepping in, saying,
you know, in every episode,
now, they're going to have,
you know, you know,
Mickey and Pluto going at it.
[ Laughter ]
Like really?
-Thank you for that image,
Senator.
-You know, but it's just like
come on, guys.
Like these are kids.
And, you know,
you could always shift
to Cinemax, if you want that.
-You can?!
[ Laughter ]
Which Cinemax package
do you have?
[ Laughter ]
Just remember,
anytime you come up
with some kinky idea involving
two cartoon characters,
pornography has beat you to it.
[ Laughter ]
I bet if you Googled
Mickey and Pluto,
the top autocomplete options
would be...
[ Laughter ]
The point is
Ted Cruz jumping to that
conclusion makes it clear
he already has some pretty pervy
ideas about the Magic Kingdom.
some pretty pervy ideas
about the Magic Kingdom.
[ Laughter ]
I'd hate to hear why he thinks
it's called Splash Mountain.
[ Laughter, ohs, and ewws ]
What does this man think
is going on
at the Country Bear Jamboree?
[ Sultry funk plays ]
-♪ Unh ♪
[ Laughter and ohs ]
♪♪
♪ Oh, baby ♪
[ Laughter ]
-And, by the way,
you don't have to make stuff up.
There's already
some really shady behavior
going on at Disney movies,
like this lady who's running
some kind of weird,
off-the-books mining company
[ Laughter ]
and doesn't even bother to learn
her employee's real names.
"Could you stop
calling me Grumpy?
My name is Henry Sampson
and maybe I'm grumpy
because I pay attention
to the news!"
[ Laughter ]
And now,
Republicans are so angry
at Disney's opposition
to their bigoted law
that Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis
is moving to retaliate
by revoking Disney's
long-standing special status,
which basically allows it
to run its own governing
district in the state.
-Florida's Republican governor
putting the squeeze on Disney.
Critics say he's retaliating
for the company's criticism
of the state's so-called
Don't Say Gay law,
limiting classroom instruction
on sexual orientation
and gender identity.
Ron DeSantis
urging state lawmakers
who are meeting
in special session this week
to end Disney's self-governing
district in Orlando.
-It'll never cease to amaze me
that, on one hand,
you have liberal pundits,
like James Carville,
loving to hector their own party
about being too woke or too far
from the mainstream,
but meanwhile, Republicans
are waging war on Disney
and warning that,
if we don't act soon,
a mouse that can talk
will [bleep] a dog that can't.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hey, he's the one
who brought it up!
[ Laughter ]
And look, Disney doesn't
need me to defend them.
They probably
don't even want me to,
after I made
that Splash Mountain joke.
And I don't know,
maybe no corporation
should have
self-governing privileges,
but it's a bad sign
when politicians
start using their powers
for retaliation.
And, purely
from a political perspective,
do you really think
it's a smart move
to go after Disney, Republicans?
What's next?
Are Eric and Don Jr. going to go
on one of their hunting trips
looking for Bambi?
"We got your mom, and now,
we're back to finish the job!"
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, I forgot
to say spoiler alert.
[ Laughter ]
This is the kind of thing
Republicans
are focused on right now,
as they aim to retake power
in the November midterms.
Democrats, meanwhile,
are still moving along
with their investigation
into the January 6th
insurrection,
which is still grinding on,
despite mountains of evidence
from congressional investigators
and federal judges
that Donald Trump
and his cronies broke the law
when they staged a coup
to overturn the 2020 election.
And, look, I'm all
for getting to the facts,
but can we please speed
this up a little bit?
We already know what happened
and who did it.
This is like if they changed
the name of Clue to...
[ Laughter ]
Earlier this week, for example,
the committee investigating
the insurrection interviewed
former Trump campaign official
Kimberly Guilfoyle,
who's also Donald Trump Jr.'s
fiancée,
for what seems like
an excruciating amount of time.
-New this morning,
a top Trump supporter testifies
for over nine hours in the
Capitol riot investigation.
Kimberly Guilfoyle met
with the January 6th Committee
after the panel issued
a subpoena for her last month.
Guilfoyle is the fiancée
of Donald Trump Jr.
and a former
Fox News personality
who worked for Mr. Trump's
reelection campaign.
The panel's chairman said,
in a statement,
that she "apparently
played a key role
organizing and raising funds
for the rally."
-They talked to her
for nine hours?!
I doubt Don Jr. has talked
to her for nine hours.
[ Laughter ]
I just hope they had
noise-canceling headphones on.
-The best!
[ Laughter ]
is yet!
to come!
-I am so sorry if you fell
asleep watching Fallon
and that just woke you up.
[ Laughter ]
Can you imagine listening
to that for nine hours?
Honestly, I'd rather watch
Mickey and Pluto get it on.
[ Laughter ]
And yet, still,
the people who orchestrated
and supported
the attempted coup
have not been held accountable,
like Marjorie Taylor Greene,
who is currently the subject
of a lawsuit trying
to keep her off the 2022 ballot
for trying to overturn
the election on January 6th.
And, as she made clear
on Fox News this week,
she is not happy about it.
-The progressives,
the people that donate
to dark money groups,
you know, the 501(c)(3)s
and the foundations,
they've hired up some attorneys
from New York
who hate the people
in my district
and don't believe that they
should have the right to elect
who they want to send
to Washington, which is me.
I have overwhelming support
in my district
and I'm so thankful
for all of them.
Well, now, they filed a lawsuit
because they're trying to rip
my name off of the ballot
and steal my district's ability
to reelect me
and send me back to Congress.
I have to go to court on Friday.
-It is very in line
with how I perceive
Marjorie Taylor Greene
that she's not just mad
she has to go to court,
but that she has to go
on a Friday.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Greene ] How dare you!
That's when they have $2 margs
at Houlihan's.
What am I supposed to tell the
girls in my QAnon book club?
[ Laughter ]
We're going to look
for Secret satanic messages
in the new
Danielle Steel novel.
There's plenty!
[ Laughter ]
On a different show,
Greene even expressed concern
that the press would be allowed
in the courtroom on Friday.
-They're going to allow
the press in the courtroom.
They're going to allow the whole
thing to be videoed live
out to go anywhere
in the world they want to.
And you know what?
That's going to look
like the Democrats
and the nasty mainstream media,
you know, the ones that lie
about me constantly, anyways,
well, they're going to be able
to twist and turn
and clip out
any little piece they want
of the horrible things
that these funded attorneys
are going to try
to say about me.
-I'm sorry, but anyone
who still says videoed,
much less videoed live,
in the year 2022
should be disqualified
from Congress.
You sound like my grandmother
trying to explain TikTok.
[ Laughter ]
"These teens are all just
videoing themselves
walking on milk crates
and eating cereal
out of each other's mouths."
[ Laughter ]
GOP remains laser-focused
on overturning elections
and using the power
of government to retaliate
against anyone
who challenges them.
Meanwhile, Ted Cruz
is watching Cinemax,
waiting for Mickey and Pluto...
-To come!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.